hace un mes en la nueva variante del
coronavirus la de punto 1.1 529 fue
declarada como preocupante por la ms hoy
anunciamos al ave punto 1.1 529 como
variante preocupante bajo el nombre de
omicron detectada por primera vez en
sudáfrica y conocida como omicron su
alta transmisibilidad hizo saltar las
alarmas en los gobiernos a lo largo de
todo el mundo impulsando nuevos cierres
de fronteras y dejando en un principio
aislados a varios países del sur de
áfrica
la imposición de prohibiciones de viaje
a sudáfrica y a una serie de países del
sur de áfrica son lamentables injustas y
poco científicas teniendo en cuenta que
fueron nuestros propios científicos
científicos africanos los primeros en
detectar la variante omicron ensanches
países como un reino unido francia e
italia alcanzaron el récord de contagios
en cuestión de semanas impulsando
restricciones como el retorno del porte
de mascarillas en exterior en españa
hasta un estricto confín en países bajos
pero es la variante micro tan peligrosa
como se cree los primeros análisis
sugieren que los casos de omicron tienen
un 15% menos de probabilidades de acudir
al hospital y 40% menos de
probabilidades de ser hospitalizados
durante una noche o más omicron es la
variante que más mutaciones acumula en
su genoma y por tanto la más contagiosa
y aunque sus efectos fueran más leves su
alta transmisibilidad pone en riesgo de
colapso a los sistemas de salud produce
síntomas similares a los de un catarro
común poca pérdida del olfato y más
contagios entre recuperados o vacunados
ahora un mes después de su denominación
como preocupante las investigaciones
siguen pero en este panorama la buena
noticia es que sus efectos sobre el
mundo actual son mucho menores gracias a
la combinación de la vacunación las
defensas naturales por los contagios
previos de kobe 19 y la posible levedad
del virus los científicos sin embargo
siguen recomendando la prudencia